تتساقط المياه من المنحدرات السفلية
إلى مجرى متدفق إلى جنة خضراء مورقة
عالية في جبل لبنان ،
هذا هو لبنان سواء كانت خديجة أو
الوادي المقدس لعدة قرون ، فر الناس
إلى هنا هربًا من الاضطهاد الديني أو
لتجنب القانون ، جاء آخرون إلى هنا
للفرار أحيانًا بشكل دائم  جنون
الحياة الحديثة
أو الحضارة بشكل عام ، كان
هذا الوادي أحد مواقع التراث العالمي
لليونسكو تقليديًا موطنًا للناسك من
الكنيسة المسيحية المارونية الساعين إلى العزلة في
العديد من الكهوف في هذه الزاوية النائية من
لبنان ، ولم يتبق هنا سوى ناسك واحد
للوصول إليه مشينا لأكثر من
ساعة على طول مسارات غادرة في بعض الأحيان ،
لكن عندما وصلنا أخيرًا إلى 84 عامًا من
الأب داريو إسكوبار في الأصل من
المدينة المنورة في كولومبيا ، لم يكن لديه كلمات قليلة بالنسبة
لنا كما قد يتوقع المرء أنه فعل ذلك ، لكنه
ذكر كل الأشياء التي كان في لبنان
منذ عام 1990 ونسك في وادي  kaliesha
على مدار 18 عامًا الماضية ،
لكن عزلته بعيدة كل البعد عن هذا اليوم ،
لم نكن الزائرين الوحيدين لأب
داريو.  قام ما يقرب من 200 طالب من
كبار السن في المدرسة الثانوية برحلة هنا في رحلة ميدانية
بقيادة الأخ كارلوس ماريو ماكيوين أيضًا
من كولومبيا الدنيوية الذي يشرح سبب
وجود أهمية تاريخية لأطباق أعمق
في هذا الجزء والعديد من
مزودي مخطط الموارنة هنا
قد تضاءلت الانحرافات الأرضية
عدد الناسك في لبنان إلى
مجرد حفنة قليلة من الشموع
للقديسين والشهداء ما زالت تحترق في هذه الكهوف
ولكن إلى متى
بن ويدمان سي إن إن وادي باديشة الحضري على